lalalalalalala how am i seamoth hollowly
[ __ ] Lola Lola [ __ ] holy holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't know where I'm going or
hello you [ __ ] oh hello you [ __ ] god
damn it can these goddamn fish stop
slamming their bodies into the base of
my hole I need to survive the ocean and
right now I'm not doing a good job of
that huh dodging deftly what are you uh
huh
are you important there seems to be some
sort of roaring going on around here and
I'm not stasis rifle I don't think I
have that whoa
damn you hurt bad I don't need the
terraformer that bad hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome back to
subnautica I've been having a bit of
trouble I'm going on an adventure and
this adventure includes going out on my
seamoth and hopefully the best but
probably not having the best because
everything seems to be going awry but I
need something I need one specific thing
actually I need one last part of the
Cyclops I need one last piece because
I've gotten the whole fragment and I
believe I've gotten the bridge fragment
so there's got to be another component
of the Cyclops that I have not yet
received so that's gonna be my next
objective because they improve the
Cyclops I know they did and that means
there's got to be more to it that I need
and I I imagine it is what I imagine I'm
not heart wasn't certain about it but I
imagine that it involves a whole lot
more utility speed dynamicism
attractiveness in just the general
aspect of it and overall it's gonna be
better for me it's gonna be my crowning
achievement in this reinvention of this
game but I need it I need a lot I need
it very much so because I need the
Cyclops in general so I'm coming over
here by the ship because I would imagine
that if there was anywhere that there
wouldn't be fragments of something you
would be by the goddamn ship so hoping
for the best hoping not to die Leeson
coming over in the middle of the day not
a night which is what I usually do oh
that this this right here this this is
this is a thing nope it's not nevermind
I was wrong everybody ignore me I
thought those okay have I already been
here I think I might have already been
here okay so the ship is there we okay I
guess I might as well solve the
radiation problem here boo boo boo boo
boo boo boo boo boo boo
bb-bb-bb-bb-bb-bb-bb VBB ah what the oh
[ __ ] goddamnit this piece is falling
from the ceiling this is a bit more
chaotic than it used to be oh also I
think I just remembered is the there's
something here there's something
scannable in here that's important
ooh but what but what but what but what
but what but ah Oh a power efficiency
module I don't know why that was there
and shebang okay there we go dry core
breach shield radiation dissipating in
three days trying to download attempt
with roars okay energy particle
containment of university wardens
decontamination a sequence initiated
wait there's a lot of stuff going
radiation levels are estimated to return
to safe levels in t-minus
yay that's good
okay so I'll come back in three days and
that means radiation will be fixing the
Pope fully we can download this black
box because maybe they're putting a bit
more story because there's a reason
there's a reason why damage Aurora
blackbuck device not found Oh huh that's
a sabotage yeah interesting
eighty-seven percent of the habit of
sections of the ship were rendered
uninhabitable in the time who pressure
compensator me likey that okay I'm
getting out of here because I just
looked it up the last piece for the
Cyclops is either in the mountain area
or the underwater mountains and the
underwater islands the floating islands
I was actually just there um but I
didn't go explore it far enough so I
gotta go back there so I will return in
time wait a minute oh wait I just
realized this pressure compensator I
think wait hang on is this oh my god
that's a seamoth one oh but the depth is
only 300 meters now okay so they changed
it the seamoth still can't go down or
the seamoth now can't go deep but I'm
willing to bet the the cyclops can now
go like super deep and will is what i
need to explore the deep deep caverns oh
it is getting interesting
okay so somewhere around here there's a
goddamn thing what's that dot in the
distance you guys see what I'm seeing
that is distinctly something what is
that oh oh okay so this is the floating
islands so this would be also where I
need to be for the thing what is that
ow [ __ ] you oh god I'm almost dead oh
god damn it
these things come out of nowhere [ __ ]
you dude
I'm in trouble oh boy
damn it I got a bail I got a bail
because one I've been bitten to death
and two I'm completely out of water so I
need to grab some air sacks on the way
back and hope for the best
I'm gonna go for my life pod but man
this has been a journey man this is the
life has not been kind to me the ocean
has not been kind to me because the
ocean is filled with death how many
times do I need to tell you guys that
the ocean is not a friendly place no one
should go there in fact we should
probably burn it but even that wouldn't
work because it's filled with water
water doesn't burn I've tried it just
doesn't work this is gonna be close
I'm not a hundred percent about this but
I'm gonna try my best I'm over back here
okay this is good okay
whew I think we're gonna make it all
right
wasn't sure how close I was to it
there's no distance marker but at least
I got these things here give me you give
me you I will take you as well like okay
so I got these guys I got them I'm gonna
go back up to my life raft good old life
potty I actually have a welder so I can
repair this let me do that let me do
this but there but there but there and
at the power point well did this thank
you oh boy oh I had it for a ticket
nice opportunity oh wait pod 17 wait a
minute
I'm only pod 5 they said something about
coordinated coordinates attached that
means someone had to be alive to do that
way well will goal underscore wholly die
what the [ __ ] was that what does that
mean I don't know what that man but that
was weird
okay terraformer I don't need the
goddamn - oh I see something over there
whoa whoa whoa I got damnit biters oh
gosh you're good you're good
yes yes just just just eyes good okay
good good good good I got one I got one
of them I found one
now I need to find two more so long as I
can [ __ ] tomorrow I'll be a-okay now the
only question is do I go down for them
or do I try to stay a little bit up not
unnerves unsure about this
at least I got this depth module that
really did save my bacon ooh there's
something over there I'll probably a
good place to start and it's gonna be
just a hair too deep for me to get to oh
there's a lot of magnet side down here a
[ __ ] no ba ba ba ba
ah do I see a [ __ ] no hole damage please
do I see anything worth going down there
by hand
maybe we'll see alright let me go down
there again I can put on my pressure
regulator this stuff no no no no no put
on my rebreather cuz we are of the
proper depth for that sort of stuff and
hopefully that's gonna make sure that my
air lasts longer okay do you see
anything anything anything come on come
on give me give me give me give me feel
gosh that's what I was looking for
that's what I was looking for baby
that's what I was looking for that's
what I was looking for just give me one
more give me one more one more baby oh I
think it said
oh yeah baby oh yeah baby oh yeah baby
oh yeah baby oh it even unlocked the
Cyclops pressure compensator I don't
even know have to go get that anymore
that's awesome
oh that's awesome I love that I love
that I love that I love that I love that
yeah jump out here baby back home we got
some names to put on the lockers ah
that's gonna be a good day it's gonna be
a good day hello hello hello hello hi
I'm not gonna Park it in the moon pool
yet because I don't want it to drain my
entire base of power and turn it into a
goddamn horror movie but we got it we
got it oh man did we get it okay is that
all you rhenium so we have a cyclops so
we need plasteel ingot enameled glass
lubricant and advanced wiring kit now
that may seem like a lot the only thing
that I'm worried about is the enamel
glass but I actually have two teeth
already so this is not gonna be that big
of deal because plasteel needs lithium
but I have an ample supply of lithium
already so I just need the titanium
ingots I need to get more lubricant the
advanced wiring kit obviously but
everything is in working order and we
have it so I'm gonna go get those things
he'll be good oh boy shrimp - ah ba ba
doo yeah but dub de there are you give
me some bye bye my bud buy my bird dude
Oh No did you hurt yourself Oh No did
you lose a tooth probably give me more
give me feel give me five give me that
which did you drop one I can't see [ __ ]
come here teeth sorry did you die
I'll just steal it from your corpse
after you're gone
Marissa where are you were you I know I
got you hi there we go okay to talk of
teeth uh five glass all right so that
should be enough enamel glass yeah we
got it baby
of course we gotta buy us wouldn't we
got it why would we not got it okay we
reapplies yeah we did miss my kids
lubricant god dammit uh sing forever
okay while I'm here I will read the new
names on the lockers because I forgot to
do at the beginning this video thank you
to Jake more Oliver pitcher and Richard
Aaron arruda not be oh uh who I put his
are aan on my things for all commenting
thank you all so much
Jake said this was one of his favorite
series and then Oliver said if you close
your eyes for most of any episode that I
play sounds like an orgy a one-man orgy
and then Richard Aaron a root owner Pio
doesn't even know how to swim so thank
you guys so much I gotta go get stuff
BRB damn
alright this will be the last one and
computer chip and then bada-bing
bada-boom advanced wink
okay alright we did it oh my god that's
it forever okay we got it okay we got
one two three four five one two three
four five one two three four five and
then advanced wiring kit right there
where our God look ow okay so this is it
this is the moment we've all been
waiting for
where's Geoffrey Billy Sam wasn't
Marshall another up here somewhere
Geoffrey bill is a much more go to every
Billy sandwich at Marshall Debra Billy
Sam wasn't Marshall Geoffrey Billy Sam
was Marshall Geoffrey Billy Sam where's
Marshall whoa
well uh
ah there your tempura Billy's hand
wasn't Marshall I've got a job for you
I know it's the middle of the night but
frankly this is kind of important huh
all right oink oink
come Ivan oh yes yes
that is awesome you boys are amazing I
love you all
oh and it's the breaking of a new dawn I
couldn't ask for a more perfect moment
for this Cyclops to be birthed and uh oh
yeah thank you boys
Thank You boys very kindly well I'm
about to board my Cyclops Hello Baby how
you doing welcome aboard captain all
systems online whoa hey and I've got new
lockers oh but I can't I can't change
the names on those oh this is this is
cool
they updated this didn't they this looks
way cooler oh it's got upgrade modules
it's only got four upgrade modules
possible but I've already got one on my
person power efficiency which is good
our vision see now 400% which is very
very good
oh look lighting ah oh I can save power
Oh
Oh No whoa I don't know what to name it
oh I don't know what - damn it oh it's
gotta be something new ah I will leave
this up to you guys you guys tell me
what you want to name this brand-new
Cyclops and then I'll take it out for a
spin I love the fact that I can turn off
and on the lighting that is awesome
that is so cool I love the moodiness
it's so spooky in here ah that's cool
but either way there's I've been working
of really hard in this episode it's been
a long one for me maybe not long for you
guys but it's been a long one for me so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you want to name this
brand new ship I will name this and the
seamoth in the next step so thank you
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye were you watching
something in there